what was the most important story of
2019 is currently getting buried the
coronavirus is the perfect way to move
Global Consciousness away from Jeffrey
Epstein
gillane Maxwell and Jean-Luc Burnell are
currently literally in hiding to not be
prosecuted as co-conspirators they
trafficked more than one thousand women
to Epstein many of which were under the
age of 18 some as young as 12.
this apartment block he just had women
on tap he had girls on he had girls on
tap
RI told me that he has slept with over a
thousand of jean-like burnell's models
slash victims and you believe that I do
Virginia Roberts giuffray was trafficked
to British royalty prince Andrew three
times starting when she was 17 years old
Andrew claims to have no recollection of
meeting Virginia and says that this
Photograph could be doctored a polite
British way of saying fake news
because I I have no recollection of that
photograph ever being taken nobody can
prove uh whether or not
um that it that photograph has been
doctored but I don't recollect that
photograph ever being taken so as you
know prince Andrew denies the
allegations against him and he says that
this photo is a fake that he was never
there and that he's not his arm
and they're not his fingers those are
his fingers that is Andrew this photo
has been verified as an original and
it's been since given to the FBI and
they've never contested that it's a fake
and I know it's real and he needs to
stop with all these lame excuses we're
sick of hearing it
this is a real photo and that was the
first time you met him and that's the
very first time I met him and that's
right before I was abused by him
Epstein's properties were wired with
hidden pinhole cameras the Department of
Justice found compact discs locked in
his New York Mansion safe with
hand-written labels young name plus name
having this level of blackmail material
makes Epstein an obvious Target
was Epstein a construct of intelligence
communities collecting compromat
compromising material for geopolitical
strategic advantage
if so of course he couldn't live
state-sponsored manipulation of the
Elites at this scale would be
unprecedented
for almost 30 years he stayed under the
radar of the general public only in the
last year we tripped over what seems to
be one of the most important clandestine
stories of the last three decades
[Music]
now we are being treated like little
[__] kids that know the mainstream
media narrative is [__] generation
Alpha will call us insane for not
revolting against this caliber of
Cruelty and manipulation
throughout the documentary we will
leverage three critical visual designs
as foundational pillars one the timeline
two the decision tree
the questions
let's begin keeping a tab on our most
important questions
one how do we Inspire Tech and Military
intervention in capturing Elaine Maxwell
and Jean-Luc Burnell
two how do we catalyze prince Andrew in
the royal family to come clean about
their involvement
three how do we activate the use of
information found on the compact discs
4. was Epstein a construct of
intelligence communities for
geopolitical strategic advantage
here are five forward phrases that will
help us understand why this happened
take my private jet
come to my Island
stay at my mansion
I have young women
all write a check
ethics seem to fly out the window when
money luxury sex and power are offered
to humans
Epstein targeted the most primordial
instincts of the global Elite
he got more people to think with their
dicks than with their hearts
he was an ego masseuse through
pedophilic honey potting
imagine Epstein bouncing a very
attractive 22 year old woman on his knee
to taunt powerful Elites like a
sapiosexual Hugh Hefner
finding no signs of childhood trauma
what were the main reasons for Epstein's
actions
a swift climb up the bear Stearns
hierarchy to become a limited partner
after just four years in 1980.
advising the bank's wealthiest clients
on tax mitigation strategies violating
regulation D of the SEC
joining Tower Financial corporation
which imploded as one of the biggest
Ponzi schemes in American history losing
investors over 800 million dollars in
today's money
by 1991 Leslie Wexner chairman and CEO
of L brands with Flagship company's
Victoria's Secret Abercrombie and Fitch
Express Bath and Body Works granted
Epstein full power of attorney over his
affairs
Maria farmer has filed a sworn affidavit
in federal court in New York alleging
Leslie Wexner sexually assaulted her in
the summer of 1996.
Epstein attended Victoria's Secret
fashion shows hosted the models at his
New York City home and helped aspiring
models get work with the company
he became fluent in offshore tax Havens
reducing federal income taxes by 90
percent while being a part of the U.S
banking system
this cocktail of hunger for sex and
greed seems to be a perfect foundation
for what transpired
Epstein was apparently moving money in
the tens of millions in the early 2000s
and began funding heterodox science
research and education through his
foundation but where are Epstein's
financial and trading records his SEC
filings his taxes what's the source of
his wealth
in 2005 evidence of pedophilia came to
the surface which quickly avalanched
into 50 plus women with basically the
same story against one guy
anybody would be [__] for life if this
happened to them but not Epstein with a
quick visit to our timeline we see that
in 1953 Epstein was born then in 1980 he
became an LP at Bear Stearns in 1991
Leslie Wexner granted him full power of
attorney over his Affairs also in 91
Robert Maxwell died with his stolen 570
million dollar fortune in Pension funds
in 95 gallane Maxwell became Epstein's
best friend and began creating playbooks
for procuring girls in 2001 Virginia
Roberts du Frey was trafficked to prince
Andrew
from 2002 to 2004 Epstein was moving
tens of millions of dollars he began
funding heterodox science and this even
includes the former Israeli Prime
Minister the HUD Barak
and in 2005 evidence finally arose a
pedophilia
and that very quickly snowballed into 50
plus women
his lawyer Alan dershowitz who Virginia
says she was trafficked to at least six
times the earliest when she was 16
helped negotiate the deal of a lifetime
for Epstein
he ended up only pleading guilty to a
state charge of procuring for
prostitution a girl below age 18. how
did our justice system produce such a
careless result which essentially shut
down an ongoing FBI probe into whether
there were more victims and other
powerful people who took part in
Epstein's sex crimes
Alexander Acosta then the U.S attorney
for the southern district of Florida
said he offered a lenient plea deal
because he was told that Epstein
belonged to intelligence was above his
pay grade and to leave it alone
idea of what our justice system is
supposed to do after more than 100 women
made public allegations against Harvey
Weinstein on February 24 2020 he was
found guilty and sentenced to 23 years
in prison
guess what Alan dershowitz was on his
legal team
dude why do you represent people like
this why does Harvard even continue
their relationship with you
listen to these quotes from dershowitz
the defendant wants to hide the truth
because he's generally guilty the
defense attorney's job is to make sure
the jury does not arrive at that truth
here's another one
judges are the weakest link in our
system of justice
this guy is old code that is about to be
archived
let's add four more questions to our
list
five how do we find an interview Leslie
Wexner
6. where are Epstein's financial and
trading records his SEC filings his
taxes what's the source of his wealth
[Music]
seven who told Alexander Acosta to leave
Epstein alone and why
[Music]
eight why is Alan dershowitz
continuously defending sexual abusers
meanwhile gillane Maxwell has darkness
in her family
her father Robert Maxwell stole about
570 million dollars in Pension funds
affecting 32 000 people
he died in 1991 on his yacht rule the
suicide killane thinks it was a murder
she moved to NYC became a socialite met
Epstein around 1990 and began playing a
central role in both his public and
private life with many nicknames main
girlfriend Lady of the house
aggressive assistant
Epstein referred to Delane as my best
friend
she was friends with prince Andrew and
introduced him to Epstein in 1999. they
often socialized together
she created A playbook for procuring
girls targeting young financially
desperate women and helping them Advance
their careers
it was organized like a pyramid scheme
one girl Courtney Wilde brought Epstein
50 to 70 new girls some of which were 14
15 16 years of age
yeah I'm definitely targeted you know
children like myself that were
vulnerable to him and his money and um
we felt like we were being helped and
saved by him when ultimately he was just
preying on us determining criminal
liability becomes tricky when the
victims also become perpetrators
there were also several women furthering
Epstein's work acting as personal
assistants for up to 20 years keeping
names calling girls arranging travel
lodging and encounters
the amount of global Elite intertwined
with Epstein is very large many were
just friends before the surfacing of
pedophilia others were business
acquaintances some of which kept
engaging with him after his first jail
sentence and sex offender registry
like prince Andrew coming to visit
Epstein in 2010 after his sentence with
this notorious photo walking together in
Central Park
also this notorious video of him looking
out the New York Mansion door after
escorting a woman out
lastly were those that participated in
the sex trafficking
many world leaders organizations
Hollywood celebrities entrepreneurs and
even scientists got lured in
I was trafficked to other billionaires I
was trafficked to
politicians professors even royalty it
was it was the elite of the world it was
the people who run the world it was the
most powerful people in the world this
is New York this is Palm Beach this is
California this is Paris this is London
this is wherever Epstein was touching
down
he needed to have girls on constant call
girls ranged in all different ages I
mean there were girls as young as 12 you
have no doubt he was having sex with a
12 year old
I was told by him that he was having sex
with three 12 year olds sent by Jean-Luc
Burnell and Jeffrey laughed about it he
laughed he thought it was funny
what do you think when you see that
photo
there are just two of alike mind you
know they both love
having sex with young women they both
think that they can get away with
everything
that they're above society and
you know for a long time
Jeffrey was he proved it didn't he
Virginia Roberts du Frey said she
couldn't comprehend how in the highest
levels of the government powerful people
were allowing this to happen not just
allowing but participating in it
I want to remind you that in October and
November of 2016 when Wikileaks
published John podesta's emails some
people allege that they contained code
words for pedophilia and human
trafficking
in 2015 ABC News flew Virginia Roberts
du Frey to New York City for a long
interview with Amy Roebuck who was
caught on a hot mic incident thanks to
project Veritas where she claims three
years I've had this interview with
Virginia Roberts we would not put it on
the air then the palace found out that
we had her whole allegations about
prince Andrew and threatened us a
million different ways it was
unbelievable what we had Clinton we had
everything there will come a day where
we will realize Jeffrey Epstein was the
most prolific pedophile this country has
ever known
had it all three years ago so do I think
he was killed a hundred percent yes I do
because you wanna he made his whole
living blackmailing people there were a
lot of men in those planes a lot of men
who visited that Island gilan Maxwell
she knows everything
she knows she knows she should she
should be careful while she was his like
she went out and recruited all of these
girls
she should watch her back
the palace threatened us a million
different ways is a very important
segment
the UK is bullying the First Amendment
of the USA the palace is using power to
manipulate the non-dissemination of
incriminating evidence against prince
Andrew from one of our longest running
mainstream news networks ABC
was Prince Andrew's name on any of
Epstein's compact discs given the USA UK
geopolitical Alliance which since World
War II has been called the special
relationship in the Cornerstone of the
modern democratic World Order would our
department of justice go as far as to
incriminate prince Andrew by sharing
video evidence affirming that he lied
during his interview or would the doj
burn that [__] the second they found it
a lot of complicated geopolitics rest on
the best friends USA UK relationship
since it works in the palace's favor to
refuse allegations from afar why would
Andrew give the interview where even a
child can see something's fishy
time to add five more questions to our
list
eight are Robert Maxwell's 570 million
dollar stolen fortune and the 577
million dollar Fortune of Epstein won in
the same
number nine how do we find and interview
Epstein's personal assistance
[Music]
number 10 what relationship if any do
John podesta's emails have with
Epstein's sex trafficking
11. what Insight does the Royal Family
threatening ABC News to not air the
story provide
12. is the USA UK geopolitical
relationship the reason for apathy in
investigation
I would also like to remind you of the
2019 College admissions bribery Scandal
where 33 parents paid more than 25
million dollars to Rick Singer to
falsify disability reports have other
people pose as students to take the
tests get athletic coaches to lie
Photoshop kids into athlete pictures the
worst Scandal involving Elite
universities in the history of the
United States
families can make donations of 10
million dollars to inspire admissions to
take a second look at their children
money once again taking a [__] on ethics
[Music]
it is a zero-sum tournament it's not a
positive sum education it's not about
education it's a Studio 54 nightclub
you're running there have been Myriad
lawsuits against Epstein and Maxwell
many of which were surprisingly just
settled for undisclosed sums outside of
Court after accusations became public
several people and institutions returned
donations that they had received from
Epstein
Harvard University announced it would
not return any money again showing how
Elite universities are stepping in to
[__] you power
Harvard's endowment is over 40 billion
US Dollars which is more than the GDP of
each of the bottom 100 countries on
Earth
plus we still don't have a clear answer
on U.S Elite universities accepting
foreign bribes and if intelligence
agencies are exposing this vulnerability
to spy
why was Epstein even funding heterodox
science
this may be one of the most important
points of this entire documentary that
Eric Weinstein has been adamant about
drilling into our consciousness
the USA is slowly forgetting about the
group of scientists that literally
birthed the economy that we are all
flourishing in today
theoretical physicists whose discoveries
have given us semiconductors which are
the basis of all modern Electronics
Communications including Telecom the
internet GPS
electromagnetism including the Spectrum
nuclear power weapons molecular biology
which unlocked the code of life and all
the macro micro Optical Imaging
equipment the medical of which saves
your family's lives
[Music]
now if the theoretical physicists who
birthed almost the entire modern-day
industrialized world sound like a group
of people you're interested in keeping
around Jeffrey Epstein was interested in
them too as Eric puts it a Ferrari that
we left with the top down with steal me
written on it in different languages
Epstein found this Niche and other
intelligence communities from around the
world will find it too if we don't pay
the Top members of the scientific
Community who literally created our
economy it's a question of national
interest
two words
theoretical physics
[Music]
[Applause]
three more questions to add
13. what were the terms of each of the
Epstein Maxwell out of court settlements
14. why is Harvard University not
returning the Epstein money
15. was Epstein exposing the weakness of
our theoretical physics Community being
poorly funded and ready to be stolen
all right back we come to the timeline
as you remember after the evidence of
pedophilia surfaced in 2005 and
snowballed into 50 plus women in 2008
When Alan dershowitz negotiated the deal
of a lifetime when Alexander Acosta is
told to leave it alone and how Epstein
served just 13 months
from 2010 to 2019 there have been this
Myriad of lawsuits against Epstein and
Maxwell being settled for undisclosed
sums outside of court in 2010 prince
Andrew visited Epstein in New York City
after Epstein had served a sentence and
had all of the pedophilia records
exposing him
in 2015 Virginia Roberts du Frey exposes
Jean-Luc burnell's mc2 modeling agency
as sex traffickers to Jeffrey Epstein
also in 2015 ABC News interviews
Virginia and the royal family threatens
ABC
in 2016 Wikileaks publishes John
podesta's emails allegedly containing
pedophilia code words
[Music]
all right on to our next section
sir we take every inmate's life very
seriously in the Bureau of Prisons a
high profile inmate is no more important
or significant in terms of our
operations than just the average inmate
that comes our way we should be treating
people who are yet to testify against
other felons against other rapists they
have a lot more priority for your
institution don't they but you and I
both know they can make this a top
priority and get it done more quickly
than they normally would Attorney
General William Barr described Epstein's
death as a perfect storm of screw-ups
after being found unconscious six days
later taken off suicide watch signing
his last will the day before two cameras
malfunctioning two guards falling asleep
at their desks the most prolific
pedophile on trial in the United States
manages to get away without Justice
Nicholas Tartaglione was Epstein's
cellmate who was threatened by jail
guards to stop talking after describing
Epstein's death and conditions to the
media it goes without a doubt that
Nicholas should be extensively
interviewed and so should the three
executors listed on Epstein's last will
Darren K indyke Richard D Khan and Boris
nikolik
where is Epstein's trust agreement
document that was not attached to the
will
footage from the July 23rd incident of
Epstein being found unconscious was
claimed in January 2020 to be
permanently deleted due to a clerical
error
Epstein was reportedly depositing funds
into prisoners accounts to gain favors
and Buy protection
Epstein's left and right thyroid
cartilage was fractured and his hyoid
bone was broken which is said to be more
indicative of strangulation than suicide
the blood on Epstein's neck was absent
on the bed sheets
the front and back lesions on his neck
are more evident of a wire slash cord
from his CPAP machine then a strip of
bed sheet
guards say they cut him down but from
what the top bunk could someone actually
hang themselves this way
the two guards are Tova Noel and Michael
Thomas who need to tell us the exact
body position when they first
encountered him
The Noose looks like it's still hemmed
what tool did they use to cut the Noose
they took his body out of the cell
against protocol it was a crime scene
if this wasn't a suicide who how and why
did someone sneak in for this homicide
what time did Epstein's camera start
malfunctioning
even if the camera's malfunctioned in
front of a cell how about other footage
from inside the cell block area to see
if anyone else potentially entered
it is said he was buried on September
5th 2019 in Palm Beach next to his
parents in an unmarked grave to prevent
vandalism
I'm curious which medications exist that
can send him into a coma for a month and
then for him to be dug out of his grave
and resuscitated
how did Tova Noel and Michael Thomas who
failed to do their 30-minute checks on
Epstein each financed their 100
000 bail
I'd Place mandatory lifelong Financial
oversights on their accounts and Warden
lamin nadaye medical examiner Barbara
Sampson and their families to make sure
they don't get heavily compensated in
the next decades for this
they must all be extensively
investigated we know one thing for sure
a lot of powerful people are trying to
get out of this situation without
punishment
all right 16 more questions we're going
to break it up into two eight question
chunks question 16 how do we find an
interview who took Epstein off suicide
watch
17. how do we find an interview Nicholas
Tartaglione
18. how do we find and interview the
three executors listed on Epstein's last
will Darren Kate and Dyke Richard D Khan
and Boris nikolik
19. who is responsible for the permanent
deletion of the footage from the July
23rd incident of Epstein being found
unconscious
20. how do we find and interview the
prisoners whose accounts Epstein was
depositing funds onto to gain favors and
Buy protection
21. why was the blood on Epstein's neck
absent from the bed sheets
22. why are the front and back lesions
on Epstein's neck more evident of a wire
slash cord strangulation from his CPAP
machine then a noose of bed sheet
23 how could someone actually hang
themselves from the top of a bunk bed
alright the second set of eight
questions
24. what body position did Tova Noel and
Michael Thomas find Epstein's body in
25 what tool did they use to cut the
Noose and where did they cut it
26 why was Epstein's body transported
out of the crime scene against protocol
27. where is the footage from the other
cameras in the Cell Block that could
show us if anyone else potentially
entered Epstein's cell what time did
Epstein's camera start malfunctioning
28. where is the non-location disclosing
footage of Epstein being transported and
buried in Palm Beach
29. what medications could Epstein have
taken to comatize himself and get
resuscitated
30. how did Tova Noel and Michael Thomas
each Finance their 100 000 bail
31 are there lifelong Financial
oversights on guards Tova Noel and
Michael Thomas Warden lamin Nadia
medical examiner Barbara Sampson and
their families
they must all be extensively
investigated
[Music]
all right now we're gonna do the final
part of the timeline explore the
decision tree
and end with many more questions and
critical topics
okay as you remember we left off in 2016
where Wikileaks publishes John podesta's
emails allegedly containing pedophilia
code words
now we come up to July 6 2019 when
Jeffrey Epstein is arrested on sex
trafficking charges
then we move to July 23rd of 2019 where
an Epstein is found unconscious in his
cell
this is the footage that was deleted due
to clerical error
then we move to July 29 2019 when
Epstein is taken off suicide watch who
is responsible for that decision
then we move to August 8th 2019 when
Epstein signs his last will and
testament literally a day and a half
before his death
on August 9 2019 Epstein's cellmate is
transferred out and no replacement
cellmate is brought in
on August 10 2019 two cameras
malfunction two guards fall asleep and
Epstein is found dead in his cell at 6
30 A.M
from August through October 2019 the
medical examiner says it's a suicide
Michael Baden says it's a homicide and
Epstein is buried in Palm Beach
on to November 2019 when project Veritas
releases the ABC News hot mic prince
Andrew gives the BBC interview and
Michael Thomas and Tova Noel are each
released on a hundred thousand dollar
bail
and on to 2020 where Elaine Maxwell and
Jean-Luc Burnell are still in hiding we
have now experienced the coronavirus
pandemic and there are few efforts by
intelligence and journalism communities
to get to the truth
on to the decision tree I would like to
start by saying that this is a decision
tree of what I think are the most likely
outcomes obviously there are options I
have not calculated and feel free to
contribute the links to the timeline the
decision tree and the questions will all
be in the bio below this is a collective
effort let's do this
all right on the trunk of the decision
tree it splits bifurcates into two
sections dead and alive we're gonna go
ahead and start on the alive side which
is the side that I think is much less
likely
as we move up the alive side our next
bifurcation gives us two options either
he has escaped the jail and those are
fake photos of his dead body or
he medicated himself into a coma and
those are fake hanging lesions
now as we go up that part of the tree
there's another bifurcation
and that leads us to either he wasn't
even buried
or he was buried then he was dug up
and that would mean that he would be
resuscitated and that he would be alive
this would be a very elaborate
theory that would require a lot of hard
work
and physiological know-how and feels to
be much less possible
all right and let's go to the other
branch of the decision tree from the
trunk
it is the dead side
and the dead side leads us to the first
bifurcation of whether it is suicide or
homicide
now let's go up the suicide
portion
and we get to a what I think is a
trifurcation where on the leftmost
branch here you can see that it's
hanging by the CPAP electrical cord from
the bunk
the Center branch is that he over
medicated and that those are fake
hanging lesions
and the right branch is that he hung
himself by the bed sheets by a noose
from the bunk
and backpedaling down to the homicide
Branch
this is where I think things get very
interesting so the first bifurcation on
the homicide branch is that it was
either someone from inside the jail or
someone from outside the jail
and as you go up
the branch from outside the jail either
a assassin was let in
on one branch or an assassin snuck in on
the other branch
and both of those options lead us to the
most likely which is strangulation
obviously there are again other options
but that I think are less likely now on
the someone from inside the jail
committed the homicide Branch we see
that it's either a jail inmate or a jail
employee
and both Jail inmate or jail employee
would also lead us to strangulation
I'm going to share with you my
Theory after doing this investigative
documentary about where I feel the
percentages stack in the decision tree
all right so let's start with what I
think is most likely which is I think
that Jeffrey Epstein is dead and I think
that it's a homicide
and then I think that it was someone
inside the jail
a large-scale clandestine
coordinated effort
to
kill him given the amount of information
that he knew
and I think that the likelihood is
highest that it was part of the jail
staff the jail employees and that it was
uh death by strangulation and those neck
lesions especially make it pretty
evident to me from what I can tell that
it is by an electrical cord likely from
the CPAP machine
and I assign currently given the date of
publication of this investigative
documentary that
the probability of this branch of the
decision tree is approximately 60
percent
now if we back pedal a bit I do think
that it's possible that they
still had this big homicide plan but
rather than it being a jail employee it
could have been a jail inmate that's
also in on it or I think it's also
possible maybe a little bit less likely
that somebody came in from outside the
jail letting in this assassin and the
Assassin did this and that where is
again any of the camera footage that
we've been asking for from all the other
cameras inside of the jail that are not
the two that they claim malfunctioned
alright in the second uh highest
probability which I'm ascribing
approximately 25 to is the suicide
branch and the suicide branch has a 20
probability that it's a hanging by the
CPAP electrical cord from the bunk
and again that's because of the neck
lesions I think it's much more likely
that than it is a hanging by bed sheets
a bed sheet noose from the bunk I scribe
about five percent to that and then on
the alive Branch I ascribe approximately
three percent to him putting himself
into a coma and then uh being dug up or
not even buried and resuscitated so a
total that is visible right now is
and the last two percent are divided
among other options and unknowns and
again the links are in the Bible below
feel free to contribute everyone
case is probably the most blatant
example of a public murder of of a
crucial witness I've ever seen in my
entire life or anybody's ever seen this
is one of those things that's so obvious
it's so in everyone's face where was
Gillian Maxwell's passport last scene
why are we not talking to Les Wexner
where are the trading records what is
the source of the fortune seems to me
very clear that we have a missing
Fortune of Robert Maxwell in an
unexplained Fortune of Jeffrey Epstein
are those the same fortune who's asking
these questions
did everybody go to sleep when they
taught journalism in school I just don't
understand I've never experienced so
much of society and disapproval of a
mainstream narrative as we see with
Jeffrey Epstein the last time something
was such disapproval happened was
September 11 2001 which approaching 20
years later has been conveniently swept
under the carpet and sealed
another example is the 2008 subprime
mortgage crisis
or would we know anything about global
surveillance programs if not for Edward
Snowden
and don't forget the only reason we ever
learned about Co Intel Pro was because
of a Citizens commission that smelled
something fishy about our own FBI
killing citizens that were challenging
the status quo so they broke into an FBI
building stole over 1 000 classified
documents and published them through
news outlets
do you see the extent to which we as the
general public have to fight to get to
the truth
I'm 27 years old now wise enough to
investigate this pattern of Black Swan
events and red pill myself and Society
into preventing the Epstein debacle from
going through the same process
we need to address these questions and
get to the bottom of the truth to make
this stick as a collective learning
lesson second church and Pike committees
to investigate abuses of what our
founding fathers laid out as the
unalienable rights to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
we strive for the USA to lead the world
in heterodox thinking not to quell our
brightest Minds deviating from
mainstream narratives
the global Elite outside the in-group
are calling it out as it is Syrian
president Bashar al-assad said
um
free al-man Zuma
of America
it's important to hear the opinions of
XI Xing ping Vladimir Putin Tim Cook
Jeff Bezos and pretty much the elite of
every country and corporation on Earth
about their thoughts on the death of
Jeffrey Epstein
remember that on December 13
2003 Operation Red Dawn found Saddam
Hussein in a [__] spider hole in Iraq
that's how bad we wanted him
also remember how swiftly sealed Team
Six took out Osama Bin Laden on May 2nd
2011 in Pakistan
we create titles like the World's Most
Wanted terrorist we should create the
title The World's Most Wanted sex
traffickers and give equal resources to
the capture of Elaine Maxwell and
Jean-Luc Burnell imagine how swiftly the
Epstein case would get to the truth and
show the world true punishment and
Justice when you put 1 000 plus young
women's lives into drama
we need larger incentives for
information for their capture in the
millions of dollars imagine if we lost
Maxwell or Brunel to Suicide or homicide
the Epstein case would become closer to
being swept under the carpet and sealed
just like the powerful Elite want and
just like what we experienced with 911.
Maxwell and Burnell have become
reasonable targets for search warrants
based on probable cause in a high crime
like underage sex trafficking I think
Apple and Google should work with the
United States government to deliver
Justice to the victims and prevent
further perpetrators by providing phone
text email GPS records of Epstein
Maxwell Brunell
Etc if our major tech companies are not
going to provide this data during what
will be known as the most prolific
pedophilia and sex trafficking this
country has ever known then what do they
truly ethically stand for
big Tech in just 20 years has become so
intimately intertwined with society that
it has become a Gateway for foreign
influence in not only political
elections but also our everyday
Consciousness leading to things like
military Advantage the ability to steer
billions of eyeballs is unprecedented
scale that can also be used positively
to Galvanize people into Justice for
these biggest crimes preventing further
traumatic Global catastrophes
imagine greater transparency where we'd
be able to get the video camera footage
from [__] nightclub in London where
Virginia says she danced with Andrew or
have safeguards preventing the
corruption of the footage from the
cameras in the jail were high criminals
like Epstein were housed
all right eight more questions to add
number 32
What similarities does the Epstein Black
Swan event have with the cointel pro 911
subprime mortgage crisis Global
surveillance and the 2016 U.S political
election
33 how do we inspire a second church and
Pike committee
34. who is behind the idea suppression
complex preventing heterodox thinking
from emerging in the United States
35. who else in the global Elite outside
the in-group can provide valuable
insight into Epstein where is commentary
from National presidents and corporate
CEOs on Epstein
36 why is the global journalism
Community failing to gain even the
smallest breadcrumb commentary on the
Epstein story is this being killed at
the editorial or higher level
37. why have we not deemed Maxwell and
Burnell the World's Most Wanted sex
traffickers and taken them into custody
as quickly as Saddam and Bin Laden
38. why haven't Apple and Google
vocalize their compliance in providing
records of Epstein Maxwell and Burnell
39 how can we gather other insightful
data points like credit card companies
providing records of Epstein Maxwell and
burnell's transaction history or video
camera footage from places like the
[__] nightclub in London
one heretic opinion I'd like to offer is
I myself have prostituted my body for
money and power to higher status men and
women of course I'm a man doing this not
a woman creating different Dynamics but
I would encourage the women who gained
affluence in the hierarchy and are
interested in telling a heterodox story
about how they were able to accelerate
their careers through Epstein Maxwell
and the global Elite to speak as well
this is not just a one-sided story about
victims when you are flown around on
private jets stay at Mansions islands
and spend time around people worth
billions of dollars this is a
double-edged sword
any smart person will tell you to not
only get behind the eyes of the Jews in
the concentration camps during World War
II but also behind the eyes of the Nazi
prison camp guards who thought they were
doing the right thing
get behind the eyes of the orchestrator
of it all Hitler
the deepest empathy is the ability to
get behind each of those complex
perspectives and realize how it could
have easily been you in fact it was us
the same goes for all perspectives in
the Epstein case either you see this as
a large collective learning lesson for
us to integrate heal evolve and become
wiser or you think of yourself as better
than all of those involved and let your
ego run rampant to just bite you in the
ass later
the more ethically trained you are and
the more we tighten up our social fabric
to prevent our most vulnerable from
being exploited the less money luxury
sex and power will be able to bypass our
moral Gatekeepers
follow the money Trail don't get tunnel
vision
this is a big puzzle with as much clout
as 9 11. if you want to Red Pill
yourself closer to the truthful workings
of the global Elite and their power
Above the Law then keep the Epstein case
at the top of your Consciousness fight
for the military to capture incarcerate
and give Maxwell and Burnell a fair
Court Trial fight for British royalty to
stop being Above the Law and come clean
about Prince Andrew's involvement
fight for the 1000 plus women who are
telling their side of the story when it
normally gets buried by power and money
fight to end underage sex trafficking
worldwide
fight to evolve our Consciousness past
such primordial lapses in our ethics
most importantly fight for The Underdogs
fight for the most vulnerable because if
we don't step up now this is only the
beginning of getting thrown around by
plutocrats in the AI age
[Music]
eight more questions to add number 40.
how do we encourage the often quelled
heretic opinions of women who greatly
Advance their careers through the
Epstein Maxwell Brunell networks to
speak
41. how do we Inspire the empathic
practice of getting behind all
perspectives in the Epstein case
42. how do we improve our awareness of
money luxury sex and power influencing
our ethics
43 how do we integrate heal evolve and
become Wiser from this as a collective
learning lesson
44. could this be further practice
grounds for the global Elite to test how
dominating and manipulative they can be
to the masses until our Tipping Point of
revolution
circling us back all the way to the
beginning number 45 could the
coronavirus be a weapon to move
society's Consciousness away from
Jeffrey Epstein
46 how deep is the Epstein pedophilia
and sex trafficking Network that we
tripped over what is the likelihood this
was not destroyed at the root level but
will spring up again in our weak points
47 where will the approximately
577 million dollars of Epstein's Fortune
go after creditors are paid
I'm going to end this by telling you
something that I hope shakes you alive
even more than this documentary did
if you've made it this far you know as
Eric Weinstein has said we tripped over
an enormous structure
the Black Swan of Epstein is as large as
cointelpro 911 subprime mortgage crisis
Global surveillance in the 2016 U.S
political election
massive dark octopus tentacles
permeating geopolitics tied up in
institutions natural resources and the
global Elite
we are the light we give a [__] about
sense making we care for our most
vulnerable and want to architect a just
social fabric for all to unleash their
gifts
we are archiving The Old code and
ushering in the next evolution of
consciousness
we have the internet and massive
creative potentials on our side
build ideas and making
Engineers artists scientists business
people spiritual leaders get creating
there is no better time than now
[Music]
foreign